and I was warned that you know Bangkok
was a lot more dangerous than
you know a Chiang Mai Chiang Mai was
more forgiven
I remember
by this Library
one afternoon and this young side as ran
past me
and I see in another Tyrone and
behind him and he had a knife in his
hand
the guy with a nice
getting closer
that surely
a Titan X image come running out with
you know it's just a male chair I'll
just stop this kid in his tracks and
whack them
right across the face he's at the floor
this guy's on him and he's stabbing them
and it's a knife it's not a homemade
knife it's a proper knife and he's
stabbing them and the death shots
they're going in the neck they're going
in the lungs they're just it's just cold
calculating not enough friends he's just
stabbing him in the back and the legs
and and the screams you were absolutely
inhumane